[Musique]
la séance est ouverte
le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas
le procès-val est donc adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues j'ai le plaisir de saluer dans
la tribune d'honneur une délégation
conduite par Monsieur Hendrick buste
ministre président du landesnani du Nord
et plénipotentiaire de la République
fédérale d'Allemagne chargé des
relations culturelles franco-allemande
la délégation est accompagnée par notre
collègue Roland le gleux président du
groupe d'amitié du Sénat et par Monsieur
Hans Zitter Lucas ambassadeur de la
République fédérale d'Allemagne en
France
je tiens
à souligner l'importance de la
coopération étroite et de longue date
entre le Sénat et le Bundes
au service de la relation
franco-allemande
nous aurons l'occasion de réaffirmer sur
la nainement cette amitié en 2023 on
célébrant le 60e anniversaire du Traité
de les lycées
la dimension culturelle devra y occuper
une place renouvelée alors que
l'apprentissage et la pratique de la
langue part et d'autre tendent à se
faire moins fréquent nous devons
réfléchir à de nouvelles initiatives
permettant de conforter des expressions
culturelles convergentes
sans culture partager la relation
franco-allemande perdrait de sa
singularité de façon plus générale il
est crucial que nos deux assemblées
œuvrent à la nécessaire solidarité entre
les États membres de l'Union européenne
face au défi majeur auquel elle est
aujourd'hui confrontée je pense en
particulier je pense en particulier que
la crise énergétique qui sévit
aujourd'hui appelle de notre part une
réponse qui soit à la fois commune et
solidaire afin de préserver l'unité de
la zone euro et la force de nos
économies alors dans la première
ministre l'homme et Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues en votre
nom à tous mes chers collègues
permettez-moi de souhaiter
et à sa délégation la plus cordiale
bienvenue au Sénat
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement la
séance est retransmises en direct sur
Public Sénat et sur notre site internet
au nom du bureau du chaînage j'appelle
chacun et chacune d'entre vous mes chers
collègues a observé au cours de nos
échanges une des valeurs essentielles
ici au Sénat le respect le respect des
uns et des autres et celui du temps de
parole
je vais immédiatement donner la parole
au président François Patriat pour le
grau du rassemblement des démocrates
progressiste et indépendants vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le Président gardez votre
téléphone pour vous merci monsieur le
président madame la Première ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègue ma question fera écho à
vos propos monsieur le Président
puisqu'elle portera sur l'énergie le
prix l'énergie qui préoccupe beaucoup
nos concitoyens et qui les inquiète
l'inquiétude elle est chez les
particuliers l'inquiétude elle est chez
les entrepreneurs chez les agriculteurs
l'inquiétude elle est aussi chez les
maires et dans les collectivités locales
je mesure aujourd'hui l'effort qui a été
fait par le gouvernement au cours de ces
derniers mois pour faire face à ce défi
ils ont été les réponses ont été
nombreuses elles ont été efficaces je
pense aux bouclier
énergétique je pense au prix de
l'énergie je pense à la charte des
fournisseurs qui a été signé ce matin
même
cela a permis d'une part de juguler
l'inflation ce qui nous permet d'être en
Europe ceux qui ont le moins d'inflation
aujourd'hui ce qui a permis de préserver
le pouvoir d'achat
une composante comprenons bien aussi
aujourd'hui que s'il mesure à court
terme ne suffiront pas il faudra la
participation de tous il nous faudra un
changement d'attitude il nous faudra de
la sobriété il nous faudra inventer de
nouveaux pistes le Conseil européen avec
Madame panière une hachée qui s'est tenu
cette semaine vendredi à des ministres
de l'énergie est arrivé déjà à certaines
conclusions positives notamment la
conclusion de faire en sorte d'une
contribution une contribution sur les
producteurs de pétrole et sur les
producteurs d'énergie aujourd'hui nous
ne pouvons rester là vous avez évoqué
les pistes monsieur le Président
l'essentiel se jouera pour partie au
Conseil européen de la fin de cette
semaine et là dans ce Conseil européen
il nous faudra évoquer le plafond des
prix il faudra évoquer le prix
d'électricité celui du gaz et nous
comptons bien nous le savons déjà les
efforts que le gouvernement a fait pour
y parvenir et qu'il entend y faire
aujourd'hui je rappelle mes chers
collègues que l'effort consenti pour les
boucliers et autres pour les
collectivités les entreprises et les
particuliers ont raconté 100 milliards
en trois ans à notre pays quels sont
madame première ministre les pistes que
vous pourrez évoquer vendredi prochain
pour arriver au but que nous avons de
relever ce défi énergétique je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame elisabethorn première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président François Patriat
je mesure parfaitement l'inquiétude des
entreprises et des collectivités face à
la flambée des prix de l'énergie de
nombreuses communes malgré des efforts
de sobriété importants se demandent si
elles pourront payer leurs factures et
maintenir ouvert tous leurs services
publics dans les prochains mois chez le
président Patriat c'est commune ces élus
vous les connaissez bien et les membres
de mon gouvernement et moi-même avons
échangé avec de nombreux élus locaux et
avec les représentants de leurs
associations
tous porte le même message et mon
gouvernement le porte avec eux cette
situation n'est pas tenable nous devons
agir et nous agissons alors nous
agissons d'abord à la racine pour faire
baisser les prix
les prix ne retrouveront pas les niveaux
artificiellement bas de la crise covid
mais ils ne peuvent pas non plus rester
à des niveaux artificiellement haut
tirés par la spéculation nous devons
ramener les prix de l'électricité à des
niveaux cohérents avec les coûts de
production et pour cela nous agissons
d'abord au plan européen nous y
travaillons et nous avançons bien vous
l'avez mentionné la Commission
européenne a ouvert la porte lors du
conseil de l'énergie vendredi dernier à
l'élargissement du dispositif qui a
permis de diviser le prix de
l'électricité par 3 en Espagne le
président de la République s'est
entretenu cette semaine avec le
chancelier allemand et avec la
présidente de la commission et Ursula
vanderleyan a annoncé ce matin que la
Commission ferait des propositions pour
le plafonnement du prix du gaz lors du
Conseil européen ce vendredi et je le
précise nous travaillons en parallèle au
niveau français à d'autres mécanismes
pour ramener les prix à des niveaux
raisonnables mais nous agissons aussi
pour protéger les consommateurs le
bouclier tarifaire dont j'ai annoncé
mi-septembre la prolongation en 2023 et
la mesure la plus protectrice d'Europe
la hausse de la facture de l'énergie
pour les ménages mais aussi pour les
très petites entreprises et pour les
petites communes sera limitée à 15%.
ensuite je prends un engagement devant
vous aucune collectivité ni aucune
entreprise ne sera laissée dans une
impasse je pense en particulier aux
collectivités les plus exposées comme
celle qui connaissent des activités
saisonnières ou qui gèrent de grosses
équipement les ministres de l'économie
et de l'énergie ont réuni ce matin les
fournisseurs d'énergie les engagements
pris vont permettre qu'il n'y ait plus
d'entreprises ou de collectivités sans
fournisseurs d'énergie des offres seront
faites à chacun et la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie va publier des
indicateurs de prix pour que chacun
puisse vérifier que les les offres ne
sont pas abusives par ailleurs
s'agissant des entreprises nous allons
améliorer les aides exceptionnelles pour
les gros consommateurs d'énergie
s'agissant des collectivités elle
bénéficient d'ores et déjà d'acompte
pour soutenir leur trésorerie et le fait
filer de sécurité mis en place pour
traiter les cas les plus difficiles sera
renforcée le gouvernement présentera
prochainement des propositions donc vous
voyez monsieur le Président Patriat nous
protégeons nos compatriotes nous
protégeons nos collectivités nous
protégeons nos entreprises et nous
veillerons à ne laisser personne sans
solution je vous remercie
merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste les
républicains elle a deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre le 3 mars
2017 Emmanuel Macron affirmait
publiquement un principe tout ministre
mis en examen devra quitter le
gouvernement
engagement qui fut repris par Edouard
Philippe Premier ministre et qui fut
appliqué François berousse en rappel
quelques jours après la prise de
fonction de celui-ci comme garde des
sceaux
quelques années plus tard il y a deux
jours nous apprenons que le garde des
sceaux Eric Dupond-Moretti ici présent
et renvoyé devant la Cour de Justice de
la République pour des faits commis
pendant l'exercice de ce mandat actuel
comme ministre de la Justice et rien
simplement la réaffirmation de la
confiance que vous lui donnez madame la
Première ministre
comment et quel motif a présidé au fait
que ce principe présidentiel ait été
renié désormais
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé du renouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement Monsieur Olivier Véran vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre moi
aussi je suis très heureux d'être avec
vous aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs bonjour madame la
sénatrice de la Gonterie merci pour
votre pour votre question j'ai envie de
vous dire puissiez vous être aussi
prompte à venir dédouanais et
accompagner une personne qui une fois
mise en examen aurait été innocenté que
voulait être aujourd'hui dans cette
hémicycle a demandé son exclusion pour
le simple motif qu'elle est mise en
examen et donc par définition loin
d'être condamné madame la sénatrice il
est souvent fait référence à une
jurisprudence celle du gouvernement
Balladur qui avait donné lieu à
l'éviction systématique de tout ministre
mis en examen je ne veux pas vous dire
de bêtises
je ne veux pas vous dire de bêtises mais
il me semble que sur les quatre
ministres qui à l'époque avaient été
contraint à la démission parce qu'ils
avaient été mis en examen un seul avait
été condamné trois auront donc été
privés injustement en tout cas aux yeux
de la justice de la capacité qu'ils
avaient de servir l'intérêt général et
l'État je vous dis maintenant nous
gardons-nous de jeter à nos profs
systématiques sur les serviteurs de
l'État sous prétexte qui ne
partageraient pas nos idées politiques
car vous savez que le nuage radioactif
qui découle de telles attaques va en
réalité irradiées sur l'ensemble de la
classe politique et de l'ensemble des
serviteurs de l'État et qu'en définitive
c'est la démocratie qui s'en trouve
attaquée et affaibli
vous avez madame la sénatrice en tant
que législateur dans votre grande
sagesse souhaitez modifier un terme dans
la loi en changeant le mot prévenu par
le mot mis en examen si vous regardez
les minutes des débats au Sénat à
l'époque c'est intéressant il était
précisé que le mot prévenu semblait trop
indiqué que la personne était coupable
au responsable par définition de ce qui
lui était encore à peine reproché alors
que mis en examen vous voulez vraiment
dire ce de quoi il s'agissait
c'est-à-dire qu'on allait regarder s'il
y avait lieu ou non de prononcer un acte
de culpabilité donc personne à ma
connaissance n'a été condamné je dirais
même qu'il y a un renvoi en cassation
qui a été fait dans le cadre du ministre
Dupont-Moretti ce qui veut dire qu'à
l'heure à laquelle je vous parle il est
même plus factuellement mis en examen
puisque la démarche a été suspendue en
attendant la ville de la Cour de
cassation j'espère madame la sénatrice
avoir répondu à votre question
madame de La Gontrie
madame la Première ministre plusieurs
points tout d'abord je note que le
ministre qui a répondu au nom du
gouvernement désavoue le président de la
République et des à vous le Premier
ministre Édouard Philippe dont acte
ensuite je crains et je le dis avec
solennité je crains que vous n'ayez pas
très bien compris ce qui est en train de
se passer nous parlons d'éthique
gouvernementales nous parlons du fait
que tous ici nous sommes considérés par
les citoyens français comme des
personnes qui ne sont pas honnêtes nous
avons besoin nous avons besoin de
réaffirmer l'éthique en politique je
citerai simplement ce qu'a dit François
Berrou lorsqu'il a démissionné du
gouvernement et ce sera je pense la
réponse la plus efficace il a dit je
pars car je choisis de ne pas exposer le
président de la République et le
gouvernement que je soutiens c'est
exactement ce qui est en train de se
passer sachant que un ministre de la
Justice renvoyé devant la Cour de
Justice de la République pendant
l'exercice de ses missions c'est
totalement inédit et cela va alimenter
encore plus le populisme dans le dans
l'avenir
merci
la parole
est à notre collègue Jean-Pierre
corbissez pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
président madame la Première ministre
monsieur ministre mes chers collègues ma
question concernait aussi la situation
de nos communes face au coup de
l'énergie déjà fortement impactés par
l'inflation 2022 les collectivités le
sont encore en 2023 avec une prévision
au dessus des 4%. la loi de finance
rectificative pour 2022 a mobilisé une
enveloppe de 430 millions pour les
accompagner mais nous savons déjà que
cette enveloppe sera insuffisante même
porter un milliard de tant qu'elle doit
être aussi affectée à la compensation de
l'augmentation du point d'indice des
fonctionnaires par ailleurs sa mise en
oeuvre un quête fortement les élus
locaux lesquels répartition entre les
différents niveaux des collectivités ne
sont pas connus les modalités
opérationnelles restent floues le
critère de la baisse de l'épargne brute
ne pourra être connue qu'avec le compte
administratif 2022 c'est-à-dire au mieux
en juillet 2023 comment gérer d'ici là
l'impact de la crise énergétique soit
trésorerie de nos collectivités
si la situation reste là les élus seront
confrontés à des choix cornéliens
augmenter les impôts diminuer les
investissements ou faire fermer certains
équipements on a évoqué les piscines
mais quand sera-t-il les salles et
accueillant les clubs sportifs ou les
associations culturelles voire pire nos
écoles comment préserver tout ça sans
mettre en péril les finances locales qui
rappelons-le à la différence de celle de
l'État doivent être équilibrées les
collectivités ont déjà largement
contribué à l'efforts nationales il est
temps de le renvoyer l'ascenseur un
minima les dotations versées aux
collectivités doivent être indexées sur
l'inflation comme le réclame à bon droit
l'Association des maires de France
concrètement monsieur le ministre quelle
mesure d'urgence un moyen terme et même
pour l'hiver 2023 2024 entendez-vous
prendre pour concrétiser la solidarité
avec les communes dont d'ailleurs son
orgueil président de la République à
chacune de ces visites au Congrès des
Maires de France je vous remercie pour
vos réponses la parole est communiste
que la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre monsieur de sénateur corbises
d'abord dans la continuité des propos
qui ont été tenus par la première Miss
il y a quelques instants l'action et les
globale elle se fait d'abord à une
échelle européenne pour que avant de
répondre précisément à votre question il
y a un effort coordonné pour baisser les
prix et que les mécanismes de bouclier
ne conduisent pas alimenter une rente
que par ailleurs nous sommes en train
d'essayer de récupérer avec le
dispositif qui est conçu à l'échelle
européenne et qui s'appliquent déjà pour
partie à l'électricité dans ce pays
ensuite en ce qui concerne l'année en
cours ce matin
le Comité des finances locales a été
saisi du projet de décret qui est la
traduction de ce qui a été votée dans
cette émission l'enveloppe des 430
millions d'euros dont vous avez parlé
pour précisément à la fois préciser les
règles du jeu et ce que vous évoquez sur
le fait qu'il y aura un décalage par les
comptes administratifs nous incite à
penser que des dispositifs d'avance sur
une partie de dispositif serait
disponible pour pouvoir accompagner ce
cette année transitoire plus largement
je souhaite puisqu'on parle des
collectivités locales au sens large tout
de suite expliquer qu'on a globalement
trois catégories d'abord on a celles qui
sont protégées par les boucliers
tarifaires successifs qui ont été
décidées de 4% puis de 15 c'est toutes
les communes qui ont moins de 10
salariés et moins de 2 millions d'euros
de budget ensuite on a les départements
et les régions qui sont confrontés à
l'inflation à d'autres éléments mais qui
ne sont pas impactés par les prix de
l'énergie dans les mêmes proportions que
le bloc communal qui lui est
particulièrement concerné il est
d'autant plus que les communes qui sont
au-delà du seuil que j'évoque abrite le
plus souvent les équipements publics
dont vous parlez
première action on s'efforce de baisser
les prix deuxième action nous prévoyons
des dispositifs de soutien dans le cadre
du PLF qui vous sera présenté et pour la
première fois depuis 13 ans
l'enveloppe de DGF qui est proposée et
proposé à la hausse c'est une première
depuis 13 ans je sais je n'ignorais que
certains aimeraient que ce soit
davantage je signale néanmoins que ces
premiers 210 millions d'euros marque une
rupture par rapport à des choses qui
avaient été indiquées enfin la première
ministre vient de vous le dire nous
sommes en train en ce moment de
finaliser le travail qui va nous
permettre d'expliquer comment face à une
situation que nous considérons comme
n'étant pas tenable nous accompagnons
les collectivités qui sont exposées en
insistant auprès de vous que nous avons
aujourd'hui des communes qui sont encore
couvertes par des tarifs d'énergie
qu'elles ont négociées pour des périodes
pure annuelles et d'autres qui sont déjà
entrés en zone d'exposition et qui se
retrouvent confronté au dilemme d'avoir
des tarifs plus élevés que ce que leur
finance leur permettent nous y
travaillons vous aurez très bientôt la
réponse
vous avez quelques secondes
je vous rappelle qu'il y a peu vous
étiez encore maire de cette belle ville
d'Angers auriez-vous accepté de voter un
compte administratif en déficit la
quiétude des élus locaux aujourd'hui va
se transformer en colère en juin 2023 au
moment des voies des contes
administratives à 3 mois du
renouvellement du Sénat je vous laisse
imaginer les conséquences je vous
remercie merci
la parole hématon président Guillaume
Gontard pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président merci merci
monsieur le président madame la Première
ministre a écouté à l'instant monsieur
Véran il est nécessaire et peut-être
utile de répéter deux fois une citation
d'Emmanuel Macron je cite donc dans le
principe un ministre doit quitter le
gouvernement s'il est mis en examen il
ajoutait en avril le principe le
principal danger pour la démocratie et
la persistance de manquement à la
probité parmi des responsables
politiques le président Macron a
conservé cette conduite six semaines
entre mai juin 2017 le temps d'obtenir
une majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale depuis les affaires se
succèdent à un rythme effréné la
banalisation est maintenant devise
allant même jusqu'à la nomination au
gouvernement de personnes lourdement
accusées la République exemplaire est de
devenue la République des affaires cette
semaine un nouveau cap a été franchi
avec hormis la mise en examen du
secrétaire manière générale de nellysé
une première et le renvoi du garde des
sceaux devant la Cour de Justice de la
République une première également alors
madame la Première ministre connaissant
la probité qui est la vôtre allez-vous
enfin l'appliquer à votre gouvernement
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président Gontard comme j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire à l'Assemblée
hier j'ai pris acte de la décision
rendue lundi de renvoi d'Éric
Dupond-Moretti devant la Cour de Justice
de la République comme chacun ici je
suis attaché à la séparation de
l'exécutif du législatif et de
l'autorité judiciaire je ne commenterai
donc pas cette décision en revanche je
veux rappeler deux éléments fondamentaux
pour notre État de droit
le premier c'est l'indépendance de la
justice c'est un des piliers de notre
démocratie et le second c'est la
présomption d'innocence elle aussi
protège chacun elle aussi est
primordiale dans un état démocratique
ces principes n'appellent ni
commentaires ni exception
dès lors une seule question se pose
cette situation affecte-t-elle le
fonctionnement du ministère de la
Justice
ma réponse est claire et elle se fonde
sur plusieurs mois de travail avec le
ministre alors oui le ministère de la
Justice se réforme se transforme oui le
ministère de la Justice avance et voit
ses moyens atteindre des niveaux inédits
oui des réformes profondes s'engagent
notamment suite aux états généraux de la
justice
du ministre est résolu solide et
indéfectible et pour les dossiers ou
Eric Dupont-Moretti est un justiciable
comme les autres ou pour ceux qui la pu
connaître en tant qu'avocat nous avons
mis en place un dispositif de déport il
est exigeant il est efficace il me
conduit à piloter en direct une série de
sujets je vous remercie
je suis le président
merci Madame la première Mini je pense
que vous n'avez pas bien compris le
sujet n'est pas ici la présomption
d'innocence le sujet c'est le respect de
la parole donnée qui plus est de la
parole présidentielle le sujet c'est de
ne pas ternir l'image du gouvernement de
la France le sujet c'est de disposer de
ministres à temps plein au service des
Françaises et des Français le sujet
c'est la sérénité qui incombe à la
décision de justice a fortiori quand le
justiciable et le garde des sceaux le
sujet c'est la préservation de
l'indépendance de la justice Emmanuel
Macron nous avait promis l'exemplarité
politique de mise sous François Hollande
mais il nous ramène aux pratiques
délétères des présidents de Jacques
Chirac et Nicolas Sarkozy alors que la
crise démocratique est plus profonde que
jamais alors que l'extrême droite est
aux portes du pouvoir alors que les
fascistes l'ont conquis de l'autre côté
des Alpes la responsabilité qui est à
votre devant l'histoire et considérable
madame la Première ministre il est
encore de temps de prendre la bonne
décision
la parole est à notre collègue Danny
Wattebled pour le gros plaisir et
territoires
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues depuis 30 ans
la France fait face à la perte de son
industrie faute de politique adéquate
nous en avons enfin pris conscience ces
dernières années et nous avons commencé
à prendre des mesures pourtant face à
l'explosion du prix d'énergie cette
menace est de nouveau d'actualité
le mégawater de gaz naturel redescend
difficilement sous la barre de 200 euros
les prix de l'électricité s'envolent un
président d'excédents la balance
commerciale de la zone euro à leur
demande à leur demande chuté
tous les secteurs sont concernés du
verre à l'aluminium en passant par le
ciment ou encore la scie
aux difficultés
des agriculteurs et bien sûr des
familles évoquées depuis des mois
s'ajoutent celles des entreprises elles
organisent leur activité dans les
prochains mois à la baisse
les PME annoncent et fermetures au
licenciement s'ajouteront des fragilités
importantes sur des secteurs clés et des
importations obligatoires en provenance
d'autodontinence
nos souveraineté une menacée sur bien
des aspects notamment industriels et
alimentaires certaines pelotes sont à
crânes cela risque de nuire non
seulement pour d'achat mais aussi en une
puissance économique c'est un choc
majeur de compléter pour l'Europe
l'équerre n'est plus entre pays
européens mais entre l'Europe et le
reste du monde ce qui laisse craindre de
nouvelles délocalisations
alors que l'urgence est à la suite
européenne les discussions sur le
découplage du prix du gaz et de
l'électricité rencontre des difficultés
et des actions unilatérales fragilisent
leur ensemble
je comprends la volonté de nos amis
allemands avec leur bouclier
anti-inflation mais au-delà de l'amitié
nous ne pouvons pas continuellement
subir leur choix en matière énergétique
monsieur le ministre quelles actions
comptez-vous menées pour éviter cette
catastrophe économique tant au niveau
français qu'au niveau européen
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge des comptes
publics monsieur Attal vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur water
la première ministre tout à l'heure
l'essentiel de la mobilisation du
gouvernement aujourd'hui du président de
la République c'est d'agir pour faire
baisser les prix de l'énergie sur le
marché européen la première ministre a
rappelé les échanges les réunions
extrêmement importants qui se sont tenus
la réalité c'est que nous avons une
responsabilité nous avons un objectif
c'est d'empêcher que la crise de
l'énergie se traduise par des
difficultés économiques supplémentaires
cet objectif il nous anime en réalité
depuis plus d'un an maintenant et nous
avons d'ores et déjà pris des mesures
avec le bouclier énergétique avec des
mesures plus spécifiques pour soutenir
le secteur industriel que vous évoquez
cette année avec notamment les mesures
sur la reine ce sont 45 000 emplois
industriels qui ont été sauvés cette
année en 2022 dans 150 établissements
par les mesures que nous avons prises il
faut donc continuer à agir un en
refroidissant le marché de l'énergie
avec les propositions que fait la France
et que porte la France pour décupler le
prix d'électricité du prix du gaz avec
les mesures qui ont été annoncées par
Bruno Le Maire ce matin c'est le premier
objectif et le deuxième objectif c'est
d'accompagner les entreprises qui sont
particulièrement fragilisées
particulièrement consommatrice d'énergie
nous avons pour cela et vous l'avez voté
cet été une enveloppe de 3 milliards
d'euros qui permet de soutenir les
entreprises qui ne sont pas au tarifs
réglementées elles peuvent se rendre sur
le site impôts gouv.fr il y a un
simulateur et elles peuvent recevoir une
aide jusqu'à 50 millions d'euros la
première lecture que nous avons eu c'est
que les critères étaient trop
restrictifs nous les avons déjà élargi
une première fois nous travaillons au
niveau européen pour pouvoir élargir
davantage ces critères et nous
travaillons par ailleurs à d'autres
mesures qui pourraient venir soutenir
les entreprises donc le message que je
veux passer c'est que depuis un an nous
avons agi et permis à nos entreprises de
tenir et que notre action va se
poursuivre et s'amplifier pour leur
permettre de tenir parce qu'agir pour
les entreprises c'est agir pour les
Français c'est permettre à nos
concitoyens de conserver notre emploi et
c'est permettre à notre économie de
rester dynamique
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Étienne blanc
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
et voici quelques jours la semaine
dernière avec le groupe d'amitié France
Arménie du Sénat nous nous sommes rendus
à Erevan avec notre collègue son
président Gilbert Luc de vinasse nous
avons effectué ce déplacement
alors que
l'Azerbaïdjan se livrait à sa énième
attaque contre le peuple et contre le
territoire arménien
quelques jours auparavant madame
vanderleyen s'était rendu à Bakou
capitale de l'Azerbaïdjan est là elle
avait signé un accord gazier pour
assurer la sécurité des livraisons de
gaz au profit de l'Europe la concordance
de ces deux événements ne s'arrêtaient
fortuite pour le peuple arménien alors
madame la Première ministre ma question
est simple aujourd'hui le gouvernement
français se sent-il solidaires de cet
accord que l'on peut juger indigne
et puis
l'Arménie a exprimé l'exprime
régulièrement son souhait d'obtenir des
livraisons d'armes de défense
la France accepte-t-elle aujourd'hui
d'être le fer de lance d'un dispositif
permettant à l'Arménie de disposer de
ces armes pour assurer sa protection la
protection de son peuple et de son
territoire enfin la France préside le
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
une demande prégnante de l'Arménie et
d'obtenir de l'ONU la présence d'une
force d'observation et d'interposition
sur sa frontière avec l'Azerbaïdjan
pouvez-vous aujourd'hui prendre au nom
de monsieur le Président de la
République l'engagement que la France
déploiera des efforts incessants pour
que cette force d'interposition se met
en place c'est la condition de la
protection de l'Arménie et de son peuple
dont historiquement nous sommes si
proches
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre
la parole est à Madame la Ministre de
l'Europe les affaires étrangères Madame
Catherine Colonna vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur blanc vous le savez la France
est pleinement solidaire du peuple
arménien elle a toujours été où il avait
dit elle a toujours été parce que nos
histoires ont été liées depuis que notre
pays a accueilli les rescapés du
génocide arménien de 2015
elle est aux côtés de 1915 pardonnez-moi
merci Madame la premier elle est aux
côtés du peuple arménien il est
solidaires du peuple arménien le
restaurant c'est ce que nous parvenions
en règlement négocié et pacifique du
conflit qui oppose à l'Azerbaïdjan les
armes ont assez parlées monsieur le
sénateur les incursions armées de
l'Azerbaïdjan et les frappes menées
contre le territoire internationalement
reconnu de leur mini constitue une
violation de la Charte des Nations Unies
elles doivent cesser nous l'avons dit je
le répète ici même nous nous mobilisons
aussi pour obtenir la libération des
prisonniers Arméniens prisonniers de
guerre et je peux vous faire savoir que
17 d'entre eux ont été libérés hier par
l'Azerbaïdjan alors la France avec
l'Union européenne est engagée dans un
processus de dialogue entre les deux
pays qui se poursuivent en ce moment
même et que le Président de la
République poursuivra demain avec un
certain nombre de ses collègues
européens parce que c'est l'attachement
à la paix
et au droit international qui guident
notre action et c'est ainsi que sera
garantit le droit de l'Arménie à vivre
libre nous avons aussi réuni monsieur le
sénateur le Conseil de sécurité sous
président françaises à deux reprises les
15 et 16 septembre parce que oui le
Conseil de sécurité peut avoir un rôle
vous avez raison mais comme la priorité
immédiate est de faire baisser les
tensions et que pour cela il faut
établir un constat objectif de la
situation la frontière nous œuvrons
concrètement à obtenir l'envoi rapide
d'une mission d'établissement des faits
de l'OSCE et je lui ai demandé au
président d'exercice de cette
organisation il y a quelques jours à
peine je vous remercie merci la parole
est maintenant à Madame Annick billon
pour le groupe de l'Union centriste vous
avez la parole madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre dans notre rapport
sénatorial porno l'enfer du décor avec
mes trois collègues Cora porteurs
Alexandra borque Fontain Laurence Cohen
et Laurence Rossignol nous avons pour la
première fois dans l'histoire du
Parlement révélé les deux sous sordides
de cette industrie de la pornographie
une industrie qui génère des milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires chaque
année dans des conditions opaques une
industrie qui a fait de la
marchandisation du corps et de la
sexualité des femmes un business à
l'échelle mondiale la consommation de
porno aujourd'hui est massive elle
représente plus d'un quart de tout le
trafic vidéo en ligne dans le monde le
site pornhub cumule à lui seul plus de
40 milliards de visites annuelles et
près de 220 000 vidéos vu chaque minute
dans le monde
notre rapport dresse un tableau très
sombre mais réaliste des pratiques de
cette industrie violence systémique
envers les femmes exploitation de leur
précarité économique et sociales acte de
torture et de barbarie les deux affaires
judiciaires en cours en France en
témoignent elles ne sont que la partie
émergée de l'iceberg nous appelons à
sortir de toute vision datée faussée et
édulcoré du porno le porno aujourd'hui
ce sont majoritairement des contenus
violents dégradants humiliant
tous ces contenus sont facilement et
massivement accessibles aux mineurs deux
tiers des enfants de moins de 15 ans et
un tiers de moins de 12 ans ont déjà vu
des images pornographiques la délégation
porte unanimement 23 propositions pour
lutter contre les violences
pornographiques et leur conséquences ma
question est la suivante madame la
Première ministre comment comptez-vous
vous en parler de ces propositions
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre
délégués chargés de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et de la diversité
de l'égalité des chances de la Rome
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente Annick billon je vous
remercie pour votre question et je tiens
à saluer la qualité du travail que vous
avez effectué avec vos collègues
Laurence Rossignol Alexandra bourquieux
Frontin et Laurence Cohen votre rapport
est extrêmement
utile parce qu'il a permis de mettre un
coup de projecteur sur les dérives d'une
industrie qui pour reprendre vos mots
est une machine à broyer les femmes une
industrie qui a banalisé les violences
sexistes et sexuelles oui le porno est
un enfer pour les femmes
votre rapport propose des solutions
concrètes pour protéger nos enfants mais
pour protéger aussi les actrices de
cette industrie certaines de vos
recommandations rejoignent le travail
d'ores et des a engagés par le
gouvernement avec mon collègue Pape
Ndiaye ministre de l'éducation nationale
nous nous sommes saisis dès notre
arrivée au gouvernement du chantier de
l'éducation à la sexualité il est grand
temps que la loi de 2001 soit appliquée
dans nos écoles je pense aussi aux
travaux pilotés par Jean-Noël Barrault
et Charlotte cobel sur le contrôle
parental sur les smartphones mais nous
pouvons aller plus loin et votre rapport
alimentera grandement les travaux que
nous mènerons prochainement avec mes
collègues de la justice de l'intérieur
de la culture du numérique et de la
protection de l'enfance nous nous
rencontrons vous le savez le 18 octobre
et je sais que nous avancerons ensemble
de manière constructive je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Céline Brunin pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la Première
ministre messieurs les ministres les
réponses que vous apportez depuis tout à
l'heure montre je crois que vous ne
mesurez ni l'urgence ni l'ampleur de ce
qui attend nos collectivités comme nos
concitoyens et nos entreprises en
matière de factures énergétique et cela
malgré les nombreuses alertes formulées
notamment par toutes les associations
d'élus les 430 millions d'euros du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
que vous évoquez ont été arrachés cet
été par les parlementaires que nous
sommes et moins de 8000 communes vont
malheureusement bénéficier du fait des
critères que vous avez retenus quant aux
fournisseurs dont vous vous réjouissez
qu'ils aient signé ce midi une charte
il menaçait des communes de les couper
d'énergie si elle ne payait pas les
tarifs qui s'apparentent certains élus
locaux ont dit à durakette les sommes
enjeux sont-elles qu'il ne suffira pas
d'éteindre l'éclairage public ou de
baisser d'un degré le chauffage dans nos
écoles et on risque en effet de vivre
des coupures de services publics dans
nos territoires le comble c'est que nos
collectivités sont en train de repousser
des investissements qui permettraient
précisément de réaliser des économies
d'énergie allez-vous enfin entendre ce
cri d'alerte et examiner les
propositions qui sont sur la table par
exemple le retour au tarif réglementé de
l'énergie de vente de l'énergie pour les
collectivités
pour vous répondre la parole comme une
liste délégué chargé des comptes publics
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice brûlant nous avons tellement
conscience du sujet et des tensions et
des inquiétudes de nos collectivités que
nous consacrons l'essentiel de notre
temps je le disais il y a un instant à
agir face à cette emballement des prix
de l'énergie ma collègue Agnès rue
nacher pourrait vous en parler elle
termine ces soirées et ses nuits à
Bruxelles pour négocier les avancées sur
le marché de l'électricité et elle
commence ses journées comme ce matin
avec les fournisseurs en France
précisément pour lutter contre les
pratiques que vous évoquez donc oui nous
en avons pleinement conscience et je le
redis la première priorité et c'est ce à
quoi nous sommes en train d'aboutir
c'est de réformer le marché européen de
l'électricité pour faire baisser les
prix la deuxième priorité c'est de
soutenir et d'accompagner les
collectivités locales mon collègue
Christophe béchure appelait un instant
que nous avons saisi aujourd'hui le
Comité des finances locales du projet de
décret qui fait suite au positif de
filet de sécurité que vous avez adopté
et même enrichi au Sénat c'était
notamment le travail du rapporteur
général Husson ce que je peux vous
annoncer c'est que les collectivités
locales pourront faire une demande
d'acompte dès la semaine prochaine et
que celui-ci pourra leur être versé
entre la fin du mois de novembre et le
début du mois de décembre on parle ici
d'une prise en charge jusqu'à 70 % de la
hausse des prix de l'énergie ou de
l'alimentation pour les collectivités ou
jusqu'à 50% de la hausse de la masse
salariale liée au à l'impact du point
d'indice donc il y a cette action qui
est menée le tarif réglementé s'applique
pour 30000 des 36000 communes celles qui
ont moins de 10 salariés ou moins de 2
millions d'euros de budget pour les
autres nous avons fait le filet de
sécurité cette année nous allons plus
loin avec le PLF en prévoyant Christophe
Béchu la rappeler aussi une
revalorisation de la DGF de 210 millions
d'euros de sorte que 70% des communes
verront leur DGF augmenter l'année
prochaine et nous continuons à
travailler par ailleurs et je pense que
c'est aussi encore un enjeu qui nous
réunira dans l'examen du PLF à de
nouveau au dispositifs qui pourraient
s'inspirer aussi du filet de sécurité
pour soutenir là encore les
collectivités face à ces difficultés
liées au prix de l'énergie vous le voyez
nous sommes mobilisés sur la question du
prix pour le faire baisser et sur la
question l'accompagnement des
collectivités pour continuer à les
renforcer
non monsieur le ministre toutes les
collectivités n'ont pas accès au tarifs
réglementés notamment pour le gaz
et ce tarif réglementé va bientôt
disparaître pour tout le monde en
juillet 2023 il est question qu'il n'y
en ait plus pour personne vous pourrez
faire signer toutes les chartes que vous
voulez si vous nous démunissez si vous
démunissez la puissance publique de
moyens d'agir il ne se passera qu'une
accélération des phénomènes que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Jacqueline Eustache Brignoud pour le
groupe des Républicains
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues femmes vie
liberté ces trois mots se propagent à
travers le monde en soutien au
courageuse iranienne qui brûle leur
voile pour réclamer l'abolition d'une
loi qui les oblige à se couvrir symbole
de la soumission et le pression des
femmes dans une société patriarcale face
à un pouvoir théocratique dont elle ne
supporte plus le carcan le gouvernement
va-t-il enfin admettre que le voile est
un étendard politique au religieux quand
on y rend le voile semble être la pierre
angulaire du régime des Molas je
regrette encore votre attitude
d'opposition à tous les amendements que
nous avions déposés dans le cadre de la
loi séparatisme et que vous avez
qualifié d'amendement textile alors
qu'aujourd'hui clairement les entraves à
la laïcité dans nos écoles augmentent de
manière inquiétante et que les abayas
les camises fleurissent dans les lycées
signe de l'influence islamiste et
particulièrement des Frères musulmans
qui se diffusent dans l'esprit d'une
partie de notre jeunesse quand le
gouvernement va-t-il enfin avoir un
discours et des directives très claires
sur ce sujet
pour vos réponses la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État chargé de la jeunesse
ni du service national universel madame
elle est à Hery vous avez la parole de
la ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames engagement pour la laïcité
madame la sénatrice mais la loi
confortant les principes républicains
portés par Gérald Darmanin et ma
collègue Marlène Schiappa ont permis des
avancées réelles et nous permet de
porter en réalité des coûts aux
atteintes de la laïcité cependant madame
la sénatrice votre question elle porter
réellement sur la laïcité à l'école et
ses attentes oui aujourd'hui madame la
sénatrice il y a des atteintes à la
laïcité au sein de nos établissements
scolaires et c'est pour ça que nous nous
luttons pieds à pied comment déjà en
toute transparence en faisant appliquer
toute la loi de 2004 parce que plus que
jamais les signes religieux ni les
tenues qui pourraient être considérés
comme un sido le jeune non leur place au
sein de nos établissements scolaires
alors c'est le fruit d'un travail qui
avait été déjà porté par Jean-Michel
Blanquer et qu'on continue à porter
c'est pour cela que nous souhaitons
objectiver ce phénomène la réalité c'est
que nous avons besoin de chiffres le
ministre papendaye a décidé de chaque
mois rendre public ces chiffres au sein
de notre de nos enceintes madame la
madame la sénatrice la clarté la clarté
nous permet de nous appuyer sur le Val
des mais comme de qui rappelle que une
tenue peut être considérée comme un
signe religieux par destination si elle
est portée de manière régulière et que
le jeûne ou l'étudiant refuse de
l'enlever madame la sénatrice vous savez
que pour nous l'école et bien c'est un
sanctuaire ce sanctuaire est un
sanctuaire républicain et nous
accepterons aucune atteinte aux valeurs
de la République c'est pour ça qu'il y a
les équipes qui soutiennent les chefs
d'établissement madame la sénatrice
ainsi que les enseignants nous
appliquons la loi de 2004 toute la loi
de 2004 avec transparence et clarté
[Applaudissements]
il n'est plus il n'est plus temps de
faire semblant notre pays se fracture
sur ce sujet ces dernières années et
vous y avez contribué refusant tout
discours de fermeté des enseignants sont
abandonnés ou livrés à eux-mêmes et
parfois se censure sur leur programme
face à des exigences communautarisme de
plus en plus fortes le monde du sport
fait face au même difficulté l'ambiguïté
des discours et l'absence de directive
clair ont engendré des situations de
plus en plus ingérables et de moins en
moins supporté par la grande majorité
des Français lorsqu'un ministre ose dire
que les problèmes peuvent être réglés en
faisant appel au bon sens et à
l'expérience des équipes pédagogiques
cela revient à dire débrouillez-vous on
ne négocie pas avec la laïcité
émancipatrice de la jeunesse le voile et
la vitrine es islamistes qui savent
tirer parti de notre tolérance et de
notre faiblesse aujourd'hui les femmes
iraniennes nous démontent chaque jour au
péril de leur vie faisant face à la
police des mœurs qu'il est de notre
devoir d'avoir enfin du courage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue est nouée
Hélène Conway Mouret pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain il
y avait la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues notre
diplomatie revendique d'avoir des
partenariats privilégiés avec l'Afrique
si l'actualité la plus récente oblige à
en douter je vous conseille néanmoins
qui existent bien des échanges humains
culturels éducatifs et économiques
intemporelles alors la décision prise
par le Président de la République en
conseil de défense il y a un an de
réduire de 50% le nombre de visa accordé
au ressorti sans marocain et algérien et
de 30% pour la Tunisie touche
précisément ce qui tisse et
entretiennent ces liens cette politique
du chiffre qui se veut être la
démonstration de votre volonté de
réduire l'immigration emporte deux
conséquences délétères elle est d'abord
vécue comme une punition collective par
ceux qui ne présentent aucun risque
migratoire qui seront en France pour
certains depuis des décennies à des fins
familiales ou professionnels les
perdants se sentent quant à eux humiliés
et on exprime une aigreur et un
ressentiment dans la presse nationale se
faisait encore les causes ce matin
ce sont ensuite des appels d'offres
perdues parce que l'investisseur
étranger n'obtient pas Louisa nécessaire
il se tourne vers un autre pays plus
accueillant l'Espagne l'Autriche
l'Italie entière aujourd'hui des
bénéfices économiques et vous en
remercie de toute évidence les mesures
mises en place depuis un an se révèle
inefficace les États concernés n'ont pas
accepté de reprendre le ressortissant en
situation irrégulière l'immigration
illégale n'a toujours passé c quand aux
effets politiques et électoraux que vous
en attendiez les dernières élections
montrer la vanité de votre démarche il
est temps de laisser à nouveau le soin
au personnel expérimenté de nos
consulats d'instruire les demandes dont
ils sont saisis toutes les demandes et
se faisant refuser celles qui doivent
l'être il est temps de négocier des
accords bilatéraux en matière
d'immigration accord sans lesquels
le tissu affectif et charnel de la
relation qui nous lie à l'Afrique
s'estompera sans lendemain qu'en
pensez-vous madame la ministre
pour vous répondre la parole économique
de l'Europe et les affaires étrangères
madame Colonna
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices madame la sénatrice connu
trois pays du Maghreb madame
messenatrices la Tunisie l'Algérie et le
Maroc ont fait l'objet depuis septembre
2021 de mesures restrictives sur la
délivrance des visas ces mesures de
restriction ont été décidées par le
gouvernement vous l'avez rappelé madame
la sénatrice en réponse au constat d'une
forte baisse du nombre de laisser passer
consulaires délivré par CPI dans le
cadre des mesures d'éloignement
prononcées à l'encontre des étrangers en
situation irrégulière sur notre
territoire par le ministère de
l'Intérieur je tiens à souligner que les
discussions récentes entre les ministres
de l'Intérieur français et des pays
concernés en matière de coopération
migratoire sont positives il y a une
réelle amélioration de la situation et
qu'elle se poursuit de façon
constructive le ministre de l'intérieur
comme moi-même nous nous ont réjouissons
nous progressons encore tout récemment
il y a quelques jours à peine avec le
Maroc et nous souhaitons pouvoir
continuer d'avancer afin de mettre un
terme à cette situation
je tiens d'ailleurs à rappeler que les
mesures restrictives qui avaient été
mises en oeuvre l'ont été avec le souci
de préserver au maximum les publics
prioritaires notamment les étudiants les
entrepreneurs les artistes ou d'autres
et enfin au-delà du sujet spécifique de
ces mesures et de leur évolution en
cours ou à venir je ne les connais pas
l'enjeu des délais de traitement des
demandes de visa dans nombre de non
consulats ils sont parfois trop longs
c'est vrai nous l'entendons de tout côté
mais ils le sont tout simplement après
deux années contraintes par la pandémie
de covid-19 donc ministère immobilisé
pour les réduire j'ai décidé que des
renforts seront envoyés dans les pays
qui en ont le plus besoin et je créerai
rapidement un Centre de soutien
spécifique dédié à ces missions je vous
remercie
au vu du de la montée du sentiment
anti-français sur le contenant africain
je crois qu'il est urgent d'agir et
lorsque la politique migratoire touche
aux relations entre étage je crois
qu'elle ne peut pas être le seul fait du
ministère de l'Intérieur
[Applaudissements]
donner la parole à notre collègue
Stéphane Sautarel pour le groupe les
républicains
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre puisqu'elle
fait suite à une déclaration du
Président de la République qui impacte
de nombreuses politiques publiques de la
question migratoire à celle de
l'aménagement du territoire de
l'éducation nationale au logement le
combat pour la ruralité son
développement sa modernisation son
attractivité auto centre des
préoccupations du Sénat sur tous les
bancs de cette hémicycle alors que la
reconquête de cette ruralité qui a
cruellement manqué de vision politique
pendant des années et aujourd'hui
possible nous avons été nombreux à être
sidérés par les déclarations du
président de la République devant les
préfets il y a quelques jours en effet
le président a proposé une meilleure
répartition des étrangers accueillis sur
le territoire notamment je cite dans les
espaces ruraux qui eux sont en train de
perdre de la population et où nous
devrons fermer des classes
vraisemblablement des écoles et des
collèges dans ces régions les conditions
de la recueil seront bien meilleures que
si nous les mettons dans les zones qui
sont déjà dérangement peuplées avec une
concentration de problèmes économique et
sociaux massif a-t-il ajouté je vous
remercie donc madame la Première
ministre de bien vouloir préciser devant
la représentation nationale votre vision
de la ruralité comme de l'immigration
d'ailleurs suite à ces déclarations et
les intentions du Gouvernement pour les
mettre en œuvre y a-t-il des projets de
quota territoriaux y a-t-il un
conditionnement du maintien des services
publics à l'accueil de migrants si oui
lesquels je vous remercie
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ieurs les Stéphane sotarel la politique
migratoire de la France c'est l'un des
axes prioritaires du ministère de
l'intérieur des débats sont d'ailleurs
prévus dans les semaines à venir au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale avant
la présentation d'un projet de loi par
le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin en début d'année prochaine nous
le savons notre politique migratoire
doit évoluer pour cela nous devons être
plus ferme avec celles et ceux qui n'ont
pas leur place sur le sol français et
dans le même temps mieux intégré celles
et ceux qui ont vocation à y rester
l'intégration des étrangers en situation
régulière et lui un enjeu majeur de
notre politique migratoire et c'est
l'honneur de la France mais le système
actuel qui conduit à une trop forte
concentration sur certains territoires
n'est pas satisfaisante il suffit d'en
parler aux élus locaux concernées qui se
tournent régulièrement vers l'état pour
les accompagner face à ces situations
événements compliqués à gérer nous
devons donc mieux organiser les flux et
les accueils de migrants pour mieux les
intégrer le mécanisme de répartition
territoriale existe déjà il fonctionne
et fait ses preuves pour les demandeurs
d'asile nous l'avons d'ailleurs mis en
œuvre à grande échelle avec l'accueil
des personnes déplacées du crâne une
grande partie d'entre elles qui avaient
afflué en quelques jours dans les hubs
de Paris Strasbourg et Nice une fois
l'accueil d'urgence garantie nous leur
avons proposé d'être hébergé partout sur
le territoire et cela a fonctionné cette
politique il faut donc aujourd'hui la
développer notamment à travers des
mécanismes incitatifs c'est le travail
que nous conduisons là encore en étroite
concertation avec les territoires les
associations les élus locaux qui sont
mobilisées pour répondre aux enjeux
d'intégration d'emploi de formation
je vous remercie
madame la ministre mais je ne pense pas
que vous ayez répondu à la préoccupation
que j'ai essayé de vous faire partager
la ruralité n'est pas un sous territoire
ni pour les immigrer ni pour ceux qui
vivent d'ailleurs le problème de
l'immigration n'est pas celui d'une
répartition territoriale mais d'un
contrôle d'une maîtrise et de
l'application des textes notre ruralité
pardon accueille déjà de nombreux
étrangers et en particulier les réfugiés
ou les exilés d'i-crènes mais c'est pas
du tout le sujet que je sur lequel je
vous interroge et ceci de manière
choisie et humaine la ruralité n'a pas
effectivement aujourd'hui le cœur en
berne mais nous nous refusons à devenir
une réserve où on les parquerait au
moment où nous battons pour la prise en
compte de quelques sujets majeurs pour
notre ruralité service public école
santé aux ânes nous renvoyer cette
vision de leur ruralité et cruelle et
méprisant il semble que pour certains
nous ne soyons destinés qu'à accueillir
les migrants pour soulager les banlieues
vous l'avouez presque et les éoliennes
pour éclairer les urbains la ruralité
sous-thérite sous territoire de la
France c'est non et je pense que c'est
pas le message qui a été envoyé par les
Français au moment de l'élection
présidentielle je vous remercie merci
la parole
est à notre collègue Stéphane demi pour
le groupe de l'Union centriste et la
parole
la ministre
Bamako Bangui Yaoundé Dakar
et samedi dernier Ouagadougou partout en
Afrique le sentiment anti-français
grandit et se manifeste de plus en plus
violemment les contestataires exigent
d'une part le retrait des institutions
françaises de la gestion du franc CFA et
d'autre part ce poste à la présence
militaire de notre pays sur leur
continent les réseaux sociaux
massivement utilisés dans une gare de
l'information de la manipulation
amplifie bien entendu ce phénomène et la
présence sur le continent africain de
puissance comme la Chine ou la Russie
contribue à changer la donne Russie qui
se présente comme une alternative face à
l'impasse militaire française au Sahel
via une société paramilitaire privée que
nul n'est besoin de nommer d'ailleurs en
parlant de ces deux pays ironie de
l'histoire nous avons vendu l'immeuble
du ministère de la Coopération à des
Russes qui eux-mêmes l'ont ensuite
revendu à l'État chinois qui est
installé son ambassade certains y voit
un symbole sur notre politique vis-à-vis
de l'Afrique
bref il y a et vous le savez mieux que
quiconque une spirale exponentielle d'un
sentiment et d'actes anti-français sur
place les milliards d'euros d'être
public au développement ne change pas la
donne car ce jugement est irrationnel et
le malaise extrêmement profond par
maladresse peut-être par manque de
communication assurément nous ne
parvenons pas à convaincre ou tout
simplement à rassurer les populations
locales sur nos louables intentions en
Afrique il y avait 20 ans les slogans
anti français et du style on en a marre
aujourd'hui le slogan récurrent est
France dégage nous sommes donc en droit
de nous inquiéter sur la nature du
slogan de demain madame la ministre
comment interrompre ce processus de
dégradation de l'image de notre pays
dégradation qui impacte directement nos
entreprises présentes sur place à qui
parfois laisse 48 heures pour quitter le
territoire et qui impacte aussi
naturellement nos 250 000 expatriés
présents sur ce continent
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères madame Colonna avait la
parole
ce président mesdames
c'est vrai monsieur le sénateur la
France est victime d'une scandaleuse
campagne de désinformation en Afrique
dans laquelle certains se laissent
entraîner et qui produit des effets nous
prenons ce phénomène extrêmement au
sérieux nous allons y répondre mais nous
n'allons pas y répondre en recourant aux
instruments de ceux qui cherchent à nous
nuire nous allons tout simplement dire
et répéter la vérité la vérité c'est que
la France a doublé son aide publique au
développement depuis 2017 et que
celle-ci est très largement concentrée
dans les pays d'Afrique les plus
fragiles la vérité c'est que nous
agissons concrètement dans la lutte
contre le changement climatique pour la
santé pour le renforcement des systèmes
agricoles la vérité c'est que nous
soutenons la culture le sport la
jeunesse l'éducation les entrepreneurs
la vérité c'est aussi que nous nous
interdisons tout ingérence comme à
nouveau au Burkina Faso ces derniers
jours alors malgré cela oui nous sommes
la cible de campagne de désinformation
elles sont orchestrées professionnelles
peut-être organisé je ne reviens pas sur
vos propos
nous y répondrons en mettant mieux en
valeur ce que le partenariat avec la
France apporte au pays qui le souhaitent
c'est le sens du programme de
renforcement de nos capacités
diplomaties publiques en Afrique lancé
depuis cet été depuis cet été seulement
au sein de mon ministère il nous
permettra de rappeler les paramètres du
partenariat avec la France un
partenariat d'égal à égal respectueux un
partenariat avec les États comme avec
les sociétés civiles et qui peut
s'appuyer aussi nous le ferons sur les
diasporas présente également chez nous
je vous remercie
vous avez quelques secondes
la parole est à notre collègue Charles
Guénet pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs le ministre mes chers
collègues madame la ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
en juillet dernier lors du projet de loi
de finances rectificative le Sénat
améliorer le filet de sécurité proposé
pour les communes et les groupements les
plus fragiles en le portant à 430
millions d'euros en fin de leur
permettre de résister à l'inflation et
aux échelle du point d'indice
vous nous aviez alors précisé que ce
filet de sécurité bénéficierait à 22.000
communes sur les 35000 que notre pays
les collectivités ont de plus en plus de
doutes quand elle est efficacité de ce
filet dont je précise le CFL a refusé
des termes ce matin et elle goûte assez
peu les fuites de notre confidentiel
parvenu forte Hornu des morts à la
presse affirmant qu'elle serait en
pleine santé
pouvez-vous nous assurer qu'au terme de
ce processus c'est 430 millions d'euros
parviendront bien aux collectivités
locales et surtout comment
expliquez-vous que le chiffre évoqué en
juillet de 22000 communes sont réduits
désormais à moins de 9000 selon les
propos tenus devant notre commission des
finances il y a moins de 10 jours
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités territoriales madame
cailleux
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Charles Guénet
si on veut mettre les choses au clair au
début de l'année 2022 les finances des
collectivités se portaient plutôt bien
même si cette situation générale
dissimule est déjà des disparités la
forte influence inflation que nous
connaissons va dégrader leur finance en
2022 et père et pèsera encore plus sur
les budgets en 2023 de manière plus ou
moins forte selon les catégories de
collectivités et la part des dépenses
d'énergie dans leur budget or il est
essentiel nous le savons tous que les
collectivités préservent des marges de
manœuvre financière pour qu'elle puisse
mettre en oeuvre des services publics de
qualité et qu'elle puisse investir
massivement dans la transition
écologique le gouvernement est
pleinement conscient que l'État a besoin
des collectivités locales et doit donc
être à leur côté
c'est dans ce sens que nous avons
construit le projet de loi de finances
pour 2023 avec Christophe Béchu et
Gabriel Attal après avoir consulté dans
l'ensemble des associations d'élus dans
une méthode de concertation qu'elle
semble avoir saluer nous aurons
d'ailleurs l'occasion d'y revenir
ensemble d'ores et déjà un filet de
sécurité pour les communes les plus
fragilisées par l'inflation en 2022 a
été votée dans le cadre de la loi de
finances rectificative son décret
d'application a été présenté ce matin en
comité des finances locales vous y étiez
monsieur le sénateur selon nos
estimations plus de la moitié et les
trois cas des communes et les trois
quarts des groupements y ont ils seront
éligibles il conviendra évidemment
d'attendre la clôture des contes 2022
pour savoir qui bénéficiera
effectivement de la compensation
toutefois dès l'apparition du décret un
acompte pourra être demandé pour qu'il
puisse être versé avant la fin de
l'année une demande devra être adressée
avant le 15 novembre au service de
l'État ce filet pourra d'ailleurs et
Christophe Béchu l'a dit tout à l'heure
inspiré un nouveau dispositif de soutien
pour 2023 si le Parlement le décide lors
des discussions budgétaires merci
Monsieur Guénet
madame la ministre après les
augmentations qui plombe leur finance
s'ajoutent désormais un effort
supplémentaire et supérieur à celui que
l'État s'impose à lui-même qui sera
demandé aux collectivités sur leur
budget de fonctionnement celui-ci devra
diminuer de 0,5% de moins que
l'inflation soit un effort de 9
milliards tout ceci est conduira à
diminuer leur investissement alors
qu'elle soutiennent à elle seule près de
70% de l'investissement public or
contrairement à l'État les collectivités
ne peuvent se laisser aller à la
facilité de voter un budget de
fonctionnement en déficit ni de le
financer par la dette contrairement à
l'état elles ont fait des efforts de
gestion pour reconstituer leur
autofinancement et aujourd'hui vous
prenez argument de ces efforts pour les
sanctionner c'est leur bonne gestion que
vous apprêtez à sanctionner cette
méthode n'est pas la bonne d'abord parce
que le changement des règles permanent
rende plus en plus difficile une vision
à long terme pour les élus locaux
ensuite parce que les collectivités ne
méritent pas d'être les boucs émissaires
d'un état incapable de s'engager comme
elle dans une véritable rationalisation
de sa gestion ainsi qu'en témoigne le
presque
[Applaudissements]
la parole
est à notre collègue Martine filleul
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Madame
c'est 20 dernières années lunaire
chiffre la hausse du coût de la vie
étudiante à 400 euros avec les frais
d'inscription qui explosent et le prix
des pâtes base de l'alimentation des
étudiants qui augmentent de 21% en un an
56% des étudiants ne mangeraient pas à
leur faim
56% à Lille un tiers des étudiants vit
déjà sous le seuil de pauvreté oui en
France les étudiants ont faim et
l'inflation sonne comme un coup de grâce
pour eux oui en France les étudiants ont
froid ils vont subir un nouvel hiver
dans les logements du CROUS délabré
encore moins bien chauffé cette année
oui en France les étudiants ont peur le
traumatisme du distanciel resurgit des
universités comme celle de Strasbourg
prévoit une fermeture pour faire des
économies d'énergie
également de format sup algorithmes
opaque qu'iléante de la sélection en
master véritable épée de Damoclès le
gouvernement fait des annonces mais
elles sont sans commune mesure avec
l'ampleur la gravité et l'urgence de la
situation alors madame la ministre ma
question est simple les étudiants
sont-ils encore une priorité pour ce
gouvernement et quelle université
voulons-nous pour demain
la parole
à la ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche le même
Sylvie Retailleau
la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice d'abord je voudrais
vous remercier de remettre ce point
merci pardon je vous avais pas vu
j'étais de dos excusez-moi je voudrais
vous remercier en cette rentrée avec le
contexte de l'inflation c'est une vraie
question alors vous avez directement
répondre à votre dernière question oui
les étudiants restent au coeur de la
priorité de notre gouvernement
clairement au cœur les étudiants et
notre jeunesse on a répondu en partie
déjà avant l'été par des mesures
d'urgence qui sont appliquées
actuellement je voudrais quand même vous
les rappeler parce qu'il est bon que
tous les connaissent le premier vous
avez parlé de l'augmentation des frais
d'inscription nous avons gelé les droits
d'inscription et ceci depuis plusieurs
années comme les gels des loyers des
CROUS ont été aussi gelés le second
c'est l'augmentation des 4% de la
revalorisation des bourses pour les
boursiers puis ensuite le 3 et demi pour
les APL dans le cadre des étudiants
boursiers ou les étudiants qui ont aussi
bénéficié d'aide annuelles du CROUS où
tous les étudiants APL une aide
exceptionnelle de solidarité de 100
euros et puis évidemment la
suite du repas 1 euro pour toute l'année
universitaire se repent à un euro c'est
100 € d'économie par mois pour un
étudiant c'est plus de la moitié des
étudiants qui sont touchés par ces
mesures d'urgence à la rentrée et je
voudrais passer un message parce que je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est important
un étudiant qui est aujourd'hui en
précarité il s'adresse aux CROUS et
pourra avoir accès au repas 1 euro et
des aides très vite rapidement et des
aides d'urgence pour les problèmes
énergétiques les messages est clair pour
toutes les établissements pas au
détriment des étudiants pas de remise à
distance des enseignements et pas de
blocage de gros projets d'investissement
de nos établissements en particulier
pour la rénovation thermique énergétique
et pour le plan de sobriété les messages
ont été français et les établissements
seront accompagnés au cas par cas pour
que justement cela ne se reproduise pas
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
de votre réponse mais malheureusement
changer quelque paramètres comme vous le
suggérer n'est pas suffisant je vous
donne quelques exemples 70% des
étudiants sont exclus de l'aide au repas
à 1% et la majorité des boursiers à 1
euro
et la majorité des boursiers perçoit le
zérobis soit la somme dérisoire de 100
euros mensuel il faut madame la ministre
une refonte complète du système des
bourses comme le président Macron s'y
était engagé en 2017 car le système DZ
social aux étudiants est à bout de
souffle on ne peut pas plus longtemps
faire l'économie de ne pas investir dans
la jeunesse merci
la parole est à notre collègue Catherine
Dumas pour le groupe les républicains
merci merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer monsieur le ministre ce matin
vous avez ordonné l'évacuation du
campement du crack situé dans le square
forceval à Paris le prolongement de la
colline du crack cette colline de
l'enfer annonçait comme une opération
d'envergure dans la lutte contre la
drogue dans la capitale une question
demeure monsieur le ministre où sont-ils
allés où vont-ils aller seront-ils
soignés les opérations de ces dernières
années ont montré que les consommateurs
et leur dealer changés d'endroit
rapidement souvent d'ailleurs peu de
temps avant le passage des forces de
l'ordre cette situation reste un drame
humain considérable pour ces centaines
de personnes qui se droguent sous nos
yeux associe s'ajoutent des scènes d'une
violence inouïe qui se déroule tous les
jours dans la capitale comme par exemple
l'agression d'un bébé de policiers d'un
pharmacien d'une opticienne d'une femme
poussée sur les du métro et sans oublier
toute dernièrement l'agression
extrêmement violente d'un homme de 92
ans roux et de coup par une toxicomane à
Paris c'est une évidence le plan craque
est un échec le problème n'est pas
traité juste déplacé du 19e au 18e
arrondissement ou inversement alors
monsieur le ministre que comptez-vous
faire pour éradiquer
définitivement le trafic et la
consommation du crack à Paris
le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice en effet ce matin tôt à peu
près un millier de policiers étaient
dans le 19e arrondissement de Paris pour
procéder à la destruction après
réquisition des services de la Ville de
Paris de pourrait appeler ça une ville
je mets des guillemets parallèles celle
de la colline du crack comme vous l'avez
évoqué notamment du score de force Val
mais également pour pouvoir interpeller
les personnes qui passent leur nuit là
vous savez qu'ils sont à peu près 200 la
nuit et à peu près entre 600 et 700 le
jour tout dépend évidemment d'un certain
nombre d'alléas puisque nous avons
compté jusqu'à 17 points de deal de
crack et je veux dire que cette année
depuis le 1er janvier il y a eu 772
affaires faites par la police parisienne
et dont 584 personnes interpellées ce
qui montre à chacune à chacun le travail
qui était déjà fait auparavant mais
après m'en avoir pardon auprès de madame
la Première ministre j'ai décidé cette
opération qui permettra de laisser
pendant plusieurs jours plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois s'il le faut des
centaines de policiers à Paris entre la
place de Stalingrad jusque les deux
villes de bervilliers et pantin pour
empêcher évidemment la reconstitution de
ces villages il s'agit pas de les
déplacer mais il s'agit évidemment de
mettre fin à ce village de drogue ainsi
ouvert il y a eu ce matin 211 contrôles
de personnes 52 personnes étaient sous
la fraction la législation sur les
étrangers en gros ils étaient
irréguliers sur le territoire national
ils ont donc été conduits ils sont en
train d'être conduits dans les centres
de rétention administrative où on nous
parlons nous avons réservé 70 places de
CRA pour pouvoir justement permettre de
mettre ces personnes dans l'écran et
pouvoir les expulser du territoire
national 63 ont été mis à l'abri
notamment des femmes particulièrement
vulnérables 39 interpellations dont 17
fiches de recherche peut se gardent des
sceaux 6 infractions la législation soit
stupéfiants 11 personnes qui avaient des
armes et un pistolet automatique
d'ailleurs a été retrouvé ce matin très
tôt 5 hospitalisations d'office madame
l'État a pris ses responsabilités pour
mettre fin à ceux des autres que les
Parisiens ne pouvaient plus accepter il
faut désormais qu'en lien avec bien sûr
la santé les collectivités locales vous
le savez bien prennent aussi leur
responsabilité c'est le sens des appels
que nous avons eu avec Madame la mère de
Paris que j'ai prévenu hier c'est le
sens du travail que d'après le ministre
et moi-même appelons avec mon collègue
de la santé partenariale avec la région
Île-de-France avec la Ville de Paris
pour que l'ordre soit maintenu bien
évidemment mais que le suivi sanitaire
soit particulièrement maintenu également
un homme du bas
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur le Ministre bon je prends
note de ces éléments qui sont censés
répondre à l'inquiétude et à la colère
surtout des habitants d'irriverains mais
aussi à l'impatience des élus parisiens
avec les élus du groupe changer Paris
sous la présidence du Rachida Dati nous
prendrons d'ailleurs une initiative lors
du prochain conseil de Paris à cette
occasion nous comptons sur le plein
soutien du préfet de police Laurent
Nunez d'autant que l'exécutif parisien a
montré toutes ces dernières années son
incompétence son inefficacité en la
matière alors Monsieur le Ministre votre
responsabilité est grande ne laissez pas
perdurer dans notre capitale le plus
grand marché à ciel ouvert de crack en
France
la parole est à notre collègue Jean-Marc
Boyer pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre des Transports il
est 17 millions d'habitants du
territoire auvergnat et du Massif
Central ce désespèrent d'être les
enfants pauvres des mobilités de la
République au point que sur une carte
isoconde de la France Marseille se
retrouve au nord de Clermont-Ferrand en
temps de trajet vers Paris les ministres
passent et les trains sont toujours très
en retard sur la ligne Clermont Paris
depuis de nombreuses années et de
manière récurrente des incidents et des
retards importants pénalisent fortement
la desserte de nos territoires
Auvergnats cette situation était déjà
inadmissible elle devient totalement
incompréhensible et révoltante les
retards ont été jusqu'à 17h oui 17h de
retard en juillet dernier Monsieur le
Ministre comment pouvez-vous venir sur
notre territoire et nous dire la même
chose mot pour mot que votre
prédécesseur il a trois ans sur le plan
financier sur les travaux tant attendus
en effet des améliorations nécessaires
de la ligne n'avancent pas le calendrier
n'est pas respecté et pire
si j'ai désormais une étude
environnementale qui retardera encore
les travaux de 2 ans alors qu'il manque
déjà 130 millions d'euros pour
l'électrification de la ligne alors
Monsieur le Ministre envisagez-vous de
respecter le calendrier initial et les
financements des travaux prévus pour
vous répondre la parole comme il en
charge des transports
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Boyer vous avez raison
d'insister sur l'importance de cette
ligne dite d'équilibre du territoire car
elle a connu historiquement
d'importantes difficultés c'est exact et
vous avez rappelé un épisode du mois de
juillet qui a été particulièrement
désagréable j'ai échangé à ce moment
avec le maire je me suis rendu dès le
mois de septembre en effet à
Clermont-Ferrand parce que cette ligne
est importante c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'État engagé un effort
absolument exceptionnel ces dernières
années qui est maintenue et qui est
déployée je veux le rappeler qu'à aucun
autre projet à part une autre ligne
d'équilibre du territoire de même
importance celle Orléans Limoges
Toulouse qui les relie à Paris fait
l'objet d'un tel investissement c'est
1,2 milliards d'euros financés par
l'État pour la modernisation et la
régénération du réseau et pour la
renouvellement intégral du matériel
roulant je le confirme c'était le sens
de ma vie à Clermont-Ferrand ces
engagements seront tenus il y a en effet
je n'ai pas caché des difficultés de
calendrier l'autorité environnementale a
exigé ce n'est pas le gouvernement nous
respectons les procédures législatives
prévues par environnementale elle
s'impose à nous tous et je déplore que
cela ajoute une procédure mais c'est
ainsi et nous devons le respecter
néanmoins les délais qui
serontaires qui seront ajoutées à la
suite de cette décision autorité
environnementale seront précisées je les
partagerai en toute transparence d'ici
la fin de l'année mais il n'empêcheront
pas le déploiement notamment de
l'intégralité du nouveau matériel
roulant quant à la rénovation du réseau
elle est en cours de réalisation et
j'insiste nous tiendrons là aussi nos
engagements et nos financements il y a
un dernier point qui est lié à la
situation industrielle que vous
connaissez à la fois sur Paris Orléans
Limoges Toulouse et sur Paris
Clermont-Ferrand ce renouvellement est
assuré par l'entreprise CAF qui produit
en France et qui connaît des difficultés
industrielles comme beaucoup
d'entreprises je recevrai la semaine
prochaine le PDG de cette entreprise
pour préciser les délais de livraison et
vous avez dit
en faisant clin d'oeil bienveillant à ma
visite du 15 septembre que je n'avais
pas annoncé le d'éléments nouveaux ma
responsabilité c'est de tenir les
engagements et de réduire les
calendriers nous le ferons et surtout en
attendant d'améliorer la qualité de
service je m'y engage et nous
instaurerons un comité de suivi mensuel
qui s'installera à partir de la fin du
mois d'octobre avec tous les élus de
toutes les sensibilités j'espère que
tout le monde y participera pour
améliorer en termes de connexion le
propreté du régularité qui s'est
amélioré depuis le début de l'année le
fonctionnement de cette ligne nous y
sommes totalement engagés et je me
rendrai de nouveau avant la fin de
l'année à Clermont-Ferrand pour assurer
suivi
le ministre votre réponse est décevante
et n'est pas à la hauteur des attentes
du territoire à ce désastre ferroviaire
s'ajoute le désengagement d'Air France
qui a réduit ses vols pour
Clermont-Ferrand de 8 aller-retours à 3
aller-retour aujourd'hui quel mépris
pour notre territoire qui n'est pas à
moins de 2h de la capitale en train pour
cela le TGV Paris Orléans Clermont Lyon
doit aussi redevenir une priorité pour
l'avenir économique du Massif Central
sur le territoire dans des servis par
une ligne à grande vitesse le président
Remy Pointreau de l'association LGB pop
il travaille très sérieusement alors
Monsieur le Ministre face à ce constat
désespérant je vous le demande avec
gravité engagé avec tous les partenaires
un véritable plan de désenclamment
ferroviaire et aérien du sang de la
France et du Massif Central c'est un cri
c'est une urgence merci
merci mon cher collègue
nous en avons fini avec les questions au
Gouvernement je vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement auront lieu mercredi 12
octobre je vais suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 16h30 pour les débats
d'actualité sur le thème
atteinte au droit des femmes et aux
droits de l'homme en Iran
la séance est suspendue pour 10 minutes